NEIL: ALL RIGHT.
AISHA IN MISSION TEXAS, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, AISHAH.
LET’S GO TO REPUBLICAN ALEX
LUGO, REPUBLICAN OF TEXAS,
ADVISABLE FOR THE VICE PRESIDENT
TO STOP AT THE BORDER HAS BEEN
URGING THE PRESIDENT TO DO SO
HIMSELF.
WE DON’T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THE
VICE PRESIDENT’S PLANS MIGHT BE
AND MIGHT SURPRISE FOLKS AND GET
TO THE BORDER.
IF SHE DID, WHAT DO YOU THINK
SHE SHOULD PAY ATTENTION TO?
>> WELL, NEIL, THE
ADMINISTRATION, PRESIDENT BIDEN,
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS HAVE
ADVOCATED THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES
TO KEEP AMERICANS SAFE.
THEY HAVE ADVOCATED THEIR
DUTIES.
THE CLIP WE JUST HEARD, THIS IS
A FEDERAL ISSUE.
THE STATE OF TEXAS HAD TO
DECLARE EMERGENCIES IN 34
COUNTIES.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
WE ARE SPENDING MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS HERE IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS TO KEEP OURSELVES SAFE
MEANWHILE THE ADMINISTRATION
WANTS TO SEND $300 MILLION TO
THE TRIANGULAR COUNTRIES.
WE NEED TO FOCUS RIGHT NOW ON
WHAT THE BORDER PATROL AGENTS
NEED.
NEIL: WHAT HAS CHANGED IN THE
ADMINISTRATION IS A LOT OF THE
CASES FOR THOSE WHO ARE, YOU
KNOW, CONVERGING AT THE BORDER,
THEY USED TO BE ADJUDICATED
UNDER DONALD TRUMP ON THE
MEXICAN SIDE OF THE BORDER AND
NOW THE U.S. SIDE OF THE BORDER.
THAT’S SOMETHING THAT YOU WANT
TO SEE CHANGED BUT RIGHT NOW
THERE ARE NO SIGNS THAT IT WILL
BE.
IF IT CONTINUES LIKE THIS, THEN
WHAT?
>> WELL, IF WE ARE GOING TO
ADDRESS THE ROOT CAUSE WHICH IS
WHAT THE VICE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING, WE DO NEED TO ADJUDICATE
THOSE IN MEXICO AND BEFORE THE
CRISIS AND THE SURGE REACHES OUR
BORDERS AND THAT’S WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN CALLING FOR ALL ALONG IS TO
HAVE REMAIN IN MEXICO POLICY
REINSTATED AND HAVE THE
AGREEMENTS WITH HONDURAS, EL
SALVADOR, GUATEMALA REINSTATED
JUST LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP DID.
HE WAS WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNMENTS AND MAKING SURE THAT
THE SURGE WASN’T HAPPENING AND
THE RHETORIC IS SOMETHING THAT
THE PRESIDENT CANNOT SAY WITH
EITHER UNSAID OR POLICY THAT OUR
BORDERS ARE OPEN.
THAT’S WHAT’S BEING COMMUNICATED
TO THE REST OF THE WORLD RIGHT
NOW.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, DEMOCRATS
ENCOUNTERED, CONGRESSMAN AND THE
WAY, ENCOURAGEMENTS AT THE
BORDER HAPPENED AT THE
REPUBLICAN AND DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTS ALIKE, THAT IT
HAPPENED UNDER DONALD TRUMP ON
TWO DIFFERENT OCCASIONS IN TWO
DIFFERENT YEARS IN THE SPAN OF
HIS 4-YEAR TERM AND YOU CAN’T
BLAME IT ON ADMINISTRATION PER
SE, WHAT DO YOU SAY?
>> WELL, SURE, THIS HAS BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
TO CORRECT AND WORK TO GO
PREVENT AND FINDING SOLUTIONS
FOR.
I THINK THE KEY DIFFERENCE RIGHT
NOW IS WE’VE GOT 4 KNOWN
TERRORIST THAT IS HAVE ENTERED
THIS COUNTRY THIS YEAR.
WE’VE GOT MORE FENTANYL INTO THE
STATE OF TEXAS THAN WE KNOW WHAT
TO DO WITH.
IN FACT, THAT FENTANYL COULD
KILL 21 AND A HALF MILLION
PEOPLE IN ITS TOTAL AMOUNT.
SO WHAT WE ARE DOING RIGHT NOW
IS WE’VE COMPLETELY REVERSED
COURSE ON POLICIES THAT WE ARE
WORKING TO STEM THE FLOW TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE CORRECTING THE
CRISIS THAT’S OCCURRING.
NEIL: YOU KNOW, WHILE I HAVE YOU
AND IF YOU DON’T MIND CHANGING
SUBJECTS, WE HAVE PUSH FOR
MINIMUM GLOBAL TAX THAT
GENTLEMENJANETYELLEN SIGNED FROM
COUNTERPARTS, ITALY, FRANCE AND
OTHERS.
I’M WONDERING WONDERING WHAT YOU
THAT BECAUSE IT’S GETTING
REPUBLICANS ON BOARD WITH AN
INFRASTRUCTURE PACKAGE WHERE
CORPORATE TAXES WON’T -- WON’T
BE HIKED AS THE PRESIDENT HAD
EARLIER PLANNED BUT THIS FLOOR,
THIS 15% GLOBAL CORPORATE TAX
WOULD BE -- WOULD BE IN PLACE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> WELL, ANY TIME WE ARE RAISING
TAXES ON AMERICAN PEOPLE, I
BELIEVE THAT WE ARE DOING THE
WRONG THING.
IN 2017 THE PRESIDENT LOWERED
TAXES TO RECORD LOWS AND WE CAME
TO FEDERAL TREASURY WITH MORE
TAX RENEW IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
SO NOW WE ARE GOING TO GO INTO
THE SUMMIT WITH THE POSITION OF
WEAKNESS.
WE ARE ASKING THE PRESIDENT TO
GO WITH A POSITION OF STRENGTH
AND MEANWHILE HE’S JUST GIVING
OUR INDUSTRIES AWAY AND GIVING
OUR INSTRUMENTS OF POWER AWAY.
SO OBVIOUSLY THIS IS VERY
CONCERNING FOR WHAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DOING.
WE DON’T SUPPORT HIGHER TAXES IN
ANY WAY, SHAPE OR FORM.
NEIL: SO IF YOU GOT RID OF THE
28% TAX AND YOU HAD A 15%
CORPORATE TAX, GLOBAL TAX, YOU
WOULD NOT BE FOR THAT?
>> WELL, I THINK WE NEED TO LOOK
AT THE DETAILS AND SEE THE
ACCUMULATIVE EFFECT OF WHAT IT
DOES TO THE COUNTRY AND HOW IT
AFFECTS NOT JUST THE CORPORATE
RATE BUT TRICKLE DOWN AND AFFECT
THE REST OF THE AMERICAN
WORKING-CLASS PEOPLE.
NEIL: GOT IT.
ALL RIGHT, CONGRESSMAN, THANK
YOU FOR COMING IN.